أعتقد أن هناك
عنصرًا اقتصاديًا لديمقراطيتنا يجب أن نوليه
اهتمامًا لأن
ديمقراطيتنا لن تكون صحية
مع مستويات عدم المساواة التي
رأيناها ناتجة عن أتمتة العولمة ،
أه تراجع النقابات
أو عدم
المساواة الفاضحة الذي تفكر فيه
أخبار اليوم بشكل عام نحن لا
نتحدث عن أخبار اليوم ولكن في الوقت
الحالي لدينا
تغطية على مدار 24 ساعة
وأفهمها عن هذه الغواصة الغواصة
التي فقدت الآن بشكل مأساوي في
قاع البحر
أم
في نفس الوقت  في الوقت الحالي هنا
بالقرب من الساحل اليوناني ، كان لدينا 700
شخص لقوا حتفهم ، 700 مهاجر على
ما يبدو تم تهريبهم إلى هنا ،
ونعم ، لقد نشرنا أخبارًا لكنها لا
تهيمن بنفس الطريقة
وهي تشير من بعض النواحي إلى  الدرجة
التي نمت بها
فرص حياة الناس متباينة للغاية ، من
الصعب جدًا الحفاظ على الديمقراطية
عندما يكون لديك مثل هذه
التركيزات الهائلة للثروة ، ولذلك كان جزءًا من
حجتي
أنه ما لم نحترم ذلك ما لم
نجعل الناس يشعرون بأمان اقتصادي أكبر
ونحن
نتعامل بجدية أكبر مع الحاجة إلى إنشاء
سلالم من الفرص وشبكة
أمان أقوى تتكيف مع هذه
التقنيات الجديدة وعمليات النزوح
التي تحدث في جميع أنحاء العالم
إذا لم نعتني بذلك ، فسيؤدي
ذلك أيضًا إلى تأجيج هذا النوع  من
الشعبوية اليمينية المتطرفة في الغالب ، ولكن من
المحتمل أيضًا أن يأتي من اليسار الذي
يقوض الديمقراطية لأنه
يجعل الناس غاضبين وممتعضين
ويخيف الرئيس بايدن ، وهو رجل
تعرفه جيدًا جعل الدفاع
عن الديمقراطية نوعًا من الركيزة الأساسية في
حياته  من إدارته ،
يحدث أنه في الوقت الحالي لا
تعرف فقط تهديدات الديمقراطية من قبل
الديكتاتوريات والحكام المستبدين ، ولكن أيضًا
الديمقراطية غير الليبرالية ، كما
يطلق عليه
رئيس الصين ديكتاتورًا وهم
متمسكون بها ، وهو
يستضيف أيضًا كما نحن  التحدث برئيس وزراء
الهند مودي الذي يعتبر
استبداديًا أو على الأقل ديمقراطيًا غير ليبرالي
ما هي
النقطة التي أتوقعها أو كيف يجب أن
يتعامل رئيس مع هذه الأنواع من القادة
سواء في تسميتهم أو في
التعامل معهم ، يبدو الأمر
معقدًا أه  رئيس
الولايات المتحدة لديه الكثير من الأسهم وعندما
كنت رئيساً أه
أنت تعلم أنني سأتعامل مع أه شخصيات في
بعض الحالات كانوا من الحلفاء الذين تعرفهم
إذا ضغطت علي بشكل
خاص تعرف هل يديرون
حكوماتهم أه
وأحزابهم السياسية أه بطرق أود أن
أقول أنها ديمقراطية بشكل مثالي ،
يجب أن أقول لا بالطبع لا
ولكن كان عليك التعامل معها لأنها
مهمة لأسباب تتعلق بالأمن القومي
هناك أه تعرف
مجموعة من الاهتمامات الاقتصادية التي تعرفها ، لقد
تعاملت مع الصين
لإنجاز اتفاقيات باريس ، تعاملت مع مودي للحصول على
زوج من الدعم لأنني
أعتقد أن تغير المناخ شيء
يتجاوز أه تعرف أي
مشكلة مؤقتة معينة ، إنه أمر
مشكلة يجب على الإنسانية أن تتعامل معها
خلال العقود العديدة القادمة
بطريقة جادة
أم أعتقد أنه من المناسب
لرئيس الولايات المتحدة
حيث يمكنه
التمسك
بأه تلك المبادئ والتحدي أه
سواء خلف الأبواب المغلقة أو في الأماكن العامة
الاتجاهات المقلقة ولذا
فأنا أقل قلقًا بشأن التصنيفات التي أشعر بالقلق
بشأنها ، وتعرف ممارسات معينة
تعرفها ، وأعتقد أنه من المهم
لرئيس الولايات المتحدة أن يقول أنه إذا
كان لديك أيغور
في الصين يتم وضعهم في الكتلة.
المعسكرات وأعاد تثقيفها اقتباس أه هذه
مشكلة إنها تحد
لنا جميعاً أه وعلينا أن
ننتبه لها أعتقد أنه صحيح لو
أه أم
اجتمعت مع
رئيس الوزراء مودي فإن حماية
أقلية مسلمة في الهند ذات الأغلبية الهندوسية
هذا شيء يستحق الذكر
أه لأنه وبالمناسبة إذا أجريت
محادثة مع رئيس الوزراء مودي
الذي أعرفه جيدًا فسيكون جزء من حجتي
أنه
أه إذا لم تحمي حقوق
الأقليات العرقية في الهند  ثم هناك
احتمال قوي أن تبدأ الهند في
مرحلة ما في التفكك
وقد رأينا ما يحدث عندما تبدأ في
الحصول على هذه الأنواع من
الصراعات الداخلية الكبيرة أه أه بحيث
يكون ذلك مخالفًا لمصالح ليس
فقط الهند المسلمة ولكن  الهندوسية أيضًا ،
لذلك أعتقد أنه من المهم أن تكون
قادرًا على التحدث عن هذه الأشياء بصدق ،
فلن يكون لديك
أشياء لن تكون نظيفة
كما تريد لأن العالم
معقد ، مؤسساتنا الديمقراطية الحالية
صريره و  سنضطر
إلى إصلاحها ، لذا دعنا نسأل عن المؤسسات التي
تعاني من صرير أو عدم وجود مؤسسات في
الولايات المتحدة ، مشهد
رئيس سابق يتم
اتهامه فيدراليًا.  فسّروا لائحة
الاتهام هذه وحقيقة أن
متهمًا فيدراليًا يترشح هو قادر على
الترشح لأعلى منصب في الأرض
ربما حتى في العالم أه
إنه أقل من مثالي
لكن أه حقيقة أن
لدينا رئيس سابق يتعين عليه
الرد
على  التهم التي يوجهها المدعون
تدعم الفكرة الأساسية القائلة بأنه
لا يوجد أحد فوق القانون أه
وسيتم الآن تسوية المزاعم
من خلال إجراءات المحكمة ،
وأعتقد أنني أكثر قلقًا عندما
يتعلق الأمر بالولايات المتحدة
بحقيقة ذلك
ليس فردًا واحدًا فقط هو
أنك تعرف أن يتم اتهامه ب- تقويض
القوانين القائمة ولكن على نطاق أوسع لقد
رأينا
ما إذا كان ذلك من خلال التلاعب في
الدوائر الانتخابية سواء أكان أه تعرف
محاولة إسكات النقاد أه من خلال
تغييرات في العملية التشريعية سواء
كانت
محاولات
للترهيب  الصحافة عبارة عن
خيط من المشاعر المعادية للديمقراطية
التي أه تعلمنا رأيناها في
الولايات المتحدة ،
إنه شيء بارز الآن
في الحزب الجمهوري ولكن
لا أعتقد أنه
شيء فريد من نوعه.
أعتقد أن هناك
تسامحًا أقل مع الأفكار التي لا
تناسبنا وهي نوع من عادات
التبادل الحر والمفتوح للأفكار والفكرة
التي
تعلم أننا جميعًا نتفق على قواعد
اللعبة وحتى لو  النتائج ليست
دائمًا تلك التي نحبها ما زلنا نلتزم
بتلك القواعد أعتقد أنها أضعفت
منذ أن تركت المنصب وأه
سنحتاج إلى تقويتها مرة أخرى